أخطر قناص عرفه التاريخ
يردي ضحاياه في أجزاء من الثانية
، قتل أكثر من٦٠٠جندي أمريكي
، حتى أن هوليود أنتجت أفلام عديدة باسمه
، وصنفته أمريكا كأخطر عدو لها في العراق
، جوبا بطل عربي عراقي مسلم
، قناص بغداد الذي أذاق جيش الاحتلال الويلات،
هو صائد جنود كتيبة المارينز الأمريكية،
وضع الأمريكان مليون دولار لمن يأتي برأس جوبا
لم يترك خلفه غير فوارغ الرصاص وجثث جنود الأمريكان
(جوبا قناص بغداد )
كان ضابطا بالقوات الخاصة في الجيش العراقي السابق .
انظم للمقاومة العراقية بعد سقوط نظام صدام حسين
واحتلال العراق عام 2003،
وقتل اكثر من 646 جندي أمريكي
و أصاب 189 اخرين بين عامي 2004 و 2009
ولقبه الأمريكيون بـ جوبا وهي كلمة افريقية تعني
رقصة الموت.
.أُرسلت إليه كتيبة مارنز أمريكية
ولم يعد منهم أحد ..ولم يجدوا سوى ورقة في جيب قائد الكتيبة
مكتوب عليها جوبا مر من هنا،
فيما صنفته صحيفة دير شبيغل الألمانية
كأخطر قناص في العالم, حيث تعتمد مهارته على الاقتراب
لمسافات قريبة من الهدف مع التخفي الجيد،
و اصابة أكثر من جندي واحد بإصابات قاتلة في الرأس والرقبة
و بفاصل زمني لايتعدي 3 ثواني و 20 جزءاً من الثانية
بين هدف و اخر.
🔹️ صنفته وزارة الدفاع الامريكية كعدو خطير
و أعلنت عن جائزة مالية قدرها مليون دولار
لمن يدلي بمعلومات تقود بالقبض عليه او قتله،
وصفه أحد الضباط الامريكيين بانه لا يترك خلفه أي أثر
سوى رصاصة واحدة فارغة و ورقة مكتوب عليها "
(قناص بغداد كان هنا )
كما نصح جنوده بالرقص في حال تعرضوا للقنص على يد جوبا.
وعندما أعلن الأمريكان البدء ب٤٠ألف دولار كجائزة لمن يكشف جوبا
أعلن جوبا عن ١٠٠ ألف دولار كجائزة
لمن يظهر رأسه فوق المدرعات أو الدبابات من جنود الاحتلال
فقد بث الرعب فيهم، وجعلهم يختبئون كالفئران،،
️
وظل اسم و صورة قناص بغداد مجهولا حتى بعد مقتله
في احد المعتقلات الامريكية تحت التعذيب
دون أن يعرفوا أنه قناص بغداد, قبل الإعلان عنه
بعد ذلك أصبحت اسطورة جوبا كابوساً مرعباً
يلاحق الامريكان فكيف يتم محو هذه الأسطورة؟
..لا تسألني كيف بل ضع سؤالك
لمخرجي سينما هوليوود
فهي المطبخ الخبيث الذي يضع لنا السم في العسل
تم انتاج أفلام عديدة لتغيير فكر الكثيرين عن قناص بغداد بغرض
إنهاء اسطورته وتحويله من بطل أسطوري عربي مسلم
الى إرهابي وقاتل للنساء والأطفال كما تم تصويره لنا في فيلم
American Sniper
وتبدأ قصة الفيلم حول قناص عربي
يعمل على قنص الجنود الأمريكان الذين بدورهم يساعدون
العراقيين للنجاة من بطش صدام  وبطش المقاومة العراقية،
فاستدعت القوات الأمريكية قناص أمريكي معروف
بعد أن ضاقت بهم السبل إلى قتله،
وهو القناص كريس كايل  وهو من أشد القناصين دقة في التصويب
، وعندها يقضي على القناص الإرهابي العربي جوبا
ويدخل الرصاصة من زجاجة الناظور الخاص ببندقية جوبا
ليرديه قتيلاً في أجزاء من الثانية،
وينهي حياته بطلقة واحدة كم هذا الامر مضحك!!!
.قصة من مخيلة الكاتب والتي لا تمت للواقع بأي صلة
، فلو أجزنا ما أنتجه المخرج كلينت إيستوود وماكتبه جيسون
فلماذا لم يعرضوا لنا صورة  جثة القناص العربي جوبا
الذي قتل منهم حوالي 700 جندي أمريكي؟
ولو تم ذلك لأصبح عيداً وطنيا يتفاخر به الأمريكان
ليذلوا به العرب،
وأما الفيلم الآخر فهو فيلم " The Wall  "
من بطولة  آرون جونسن وجون سينا
حيث تدور قصة هذا الفيلم حول جنديين أمريكيين
وهم (آرون جونسن وجون سينا)
في مهمة قنص عسكرية في بغداد،
يشاهد هذان الجنديان مجموعة من جثث جنود الأمريكان
ثم يذهبان للتأكد إذا نجى أحدهم لينقذوه
فيقعان في فخ دبره أحد القناصين العراقيين وهو جوبا،
وهنا تدور الأحداث المثيرة في الفيلم
ويبدأ جوبا بالتلاعب بهم ويحاصرهم خلف جدار قديم
بعد أن أصابهم في أقدامهم للمتعة ودمر أجهزة الإرسال الخاصة بهم
ويحادثهم من خلف السور عبر جهاز إرسال لأحد القتلى
ويقول لهم بالحرف الواحد
" إذا تحرك أي عضو في  جسدكم سيكون تحت رحمة بندقيتي
" أنا أستمع جيداً لأنفاسكم  التي تصرخ من الخوف "
وفي صحراء شديدة الحرارة يصوب عليهم قنينة الماء الوحيدة
ويطبق عليهم حصار مشدد فتأتيهم الرصاص من الشمال
وتارة تأتيهم من الشرق فظنوا أنه جيش من القناصين
وعندما يتحادث معهم عبر الجهاز اللاسلكي
يجدونه شخص واحد حيث يستطيع التنقل في المواقع
أسرع من ومضة العين
مما تسبب لهم برعب كبير
.. وفي خدعة أخرى أتاح لجون سينا وصديقه
وسيلة تواصل عبر جهاز لاسلكي لأحد القتلى
كي يطلبوا النجدة والهدف كان جلب المزيد من الجنود الأمريكيين للموقع
وعندها نجح الأمر وأتت مروحية محملة بالجنود الأمريكيين
ليصعدوا إليها وهنا يُسقط جوبا المروحية بطلقة واحدة
في أحد محركاتها ويقتل الجميع وهنا كانت نهاية الفيلم.
في هذا الفيلم فقط انصفوا جوبا بالقليل من حقه، وظل الأمريكان
يتناقلون أسطورته وسيظلون كذلك حتى يأتي قناص
أمهر منه لو قدر لهم  أن يروا ذلك،،،